ich habe immer gesagt oder bei bleibe
ich auch die Abschaffung oder die
Aussetzung der Wehrpflicht war ein
Fehler es wird wieder gegebenenfalls
auch Bedrohung für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland geben und deswegen brauchen
wir die Wehrpflicht wir sind theoretisch
auch noch wehrpflichtig ist nur
ausgesetzt worden und insofern bei so
einer komplett netzkalation könnte es
uns ja auch betreffen wer Pflicht und
Zivildienst sind in Deutschland seit
Jahren abgeschafft heißt es zumindest
immer aber das stimmt gar nicht die
Wehrpflicht ist nicht abgeschafft sie
ist nur ausgesetzt könnte oder sollte
sie mit Blick auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg nicht doch wieder
eingesetzt werden denn bei vielen wächst
die Sorge das auch Deutschland sich in
nahe Zukunft verteidigen können muss
jetzt aufpassen dass die Bundeswehr
nicht in den Teufelskreis Gerät auf der
einen Seite wird sie ausgelaugt mit
Blick auf die Verpflichtungen an der
NATO Ostflanke die Abgaben an die
Ukraine und auf der anderen Seite muss
sie eigentlich Personal gewinnen bevor
wir gleich genauer auf die Pro und
Contra Argumente schauen ein kurzer
Blick zurück
in den 1990er Jahren war die
Bundesrepublik erstmals nur von Staaten
umgeben die ihr friedlich gesonnen waren
die als Verteidigungsarmee gegründete
Bundeswehr wurde deshalb neu
strukturiert und immer weiter
verkleinert 2010 dann beschloss die
damalige schwarz-gelbe Koalition das
Aussetzen der Wehrpflicht auch um Geld
zu sparen das ist ein Modell das am Ende
des Tages ja deutlich machen wird dass
die Bundeswehr kleiner werden wird sie
wird allerdings auch besser werden ein
Jahr später wurde die Wehrpflicht dann
wirklich ausgesetzt nach immerhin 55
Jahren was also spricht heute im Jahr
2023 für eine Rückkehr zu Wehrpflicht
und was dagegen das schauen wir uns
jetzt bei Kontext an herzlich willkommen
beginnen wir mit den Pro Argumenten seit
Jahren hat die Bundesrepublik
versprochen mehr für die eigene
Verteidigung auszugeben seit Jahren
drängen die USA darauf dass wir unsere
militärischen Muskeln stärken
das Verteidigungsministerium will
deshalb die Bundeswehr von rund
183.000 Soldatinnen auf
203.000 Faxen lassen die werbeauftragte
des Bundestags Eva Högl aber hält das
derzeit nicht für machbar es ist also
ein ganz gewaltiger Kraftakt wenn das
Ziel von 203.000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten bis
2031 erreicht werden soll und ich will
Ihnen hier auch sehr deutlich sagen dass
die Bundeswehr was Personal angeht enorm
belastet ist die werbeauftragte forderte
deshalb vor kurzem dass die Diskussion
um eine Wehrpflicht wieder ins Rollen
gebracht wird nun ist es nicht das erste
Mal dass in der Bundesrepublik über die
Wehrpflicht gestritten wird nach Ende
des Zweiten Weltkriegs bis 1955 hatte
die Bundesrepublik keine eigene Armee
die Politik Adenauers führte zum
Eintritt der jungen Bundesrepublik in
die Nato und damit zur festen
Westbindung im Kalten Krieg
der Preis ist hoch viele der ersten
Generäle und Offiziere der Bundeswehr
waren frühere Wehrmachtsoffiziere sogar
das deutsche Volk erwartet von Ihnen
dass Sie in Taler Pflichterfüllung ihre
ganze Kraft einsetzen für das über allem
stehende ziehen in Gemeinschaft mit
unseren Verbündeten den Frieden zu
sichern die Union war überzeugt davon
dass mit dem NATO-Beitritt der
Bundesrepublik die Verpflichtung einher
ging eine 500.000 Mann starke Armee
aufzubauen und dass dieses Ziel nur
durch die Einführung einer Wehrpflicht
zu erreichen sein die SPD hielt hingegen
an der Idee einer freiwilligen Armee
fest und seit 56 stimmte der Bundestag
schließlich mehrheitlich für die
Einführung einer Wehrpflicht für Männer
vorab protestierten die SPD
Gewerkschaften und Kirchen vehement
gegen die Wiederbewaffnung der
bundesrepubliken
ganz ganz viele Menschen die ganz ganz
große Mehrheit von Waffen von
Wiederbewaffnung von Krieg überhaupt
nichts mehr wissen auch spätere Freunde
der Wiederbewaffnung haben gesagt Franz
Josef Strauß zum Beispiel da sollen wir
hier darum abfallen als dass es jemals
wieder eine deutsche Armee gibt
entscheidend für die gesellschaftliche
Akzeptanz der Wehrpflicht war
schließlich das Recht auf
dienstverweigerung das ebenfalls ins
Grundgesetz aufgenommen wurde die
heutige Debatte um die Wehrpflicht dreht
sich hingegen vor allem um die Frage ob
eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht eingeführt
werden sollte die auch im sozialen
Bereich abgeleistet werden können
außerdem steht für viele
BefürworterInnen fest dass eine
Wehrpflicht diesmal auch für Frauen
gehen müssen kommen wir zum zweiten pro
Argument neben einer Lösung für den
Personalmangel bei der Bundeswehr
erhoffen sich einige Politiker und
Politikerinnen von einer Wehrpflicht
eine Verbindung von Zivilgesellschaft
und Bundeswehr und damit verbunden eine
höhere Akzeptanz der Bundeswehr in der
Bevölkerung ich habe das immer anders
noch ausgedrückt früher saß an jedem
zweiten oder dritten Küchentischen
Wehrpflichtiger das heißt dessen
Berichte waren nicht immer sexy oder
interessant aus der Bundeswehr aber die
Bundeswehr fand statt die heutige
Wehrbeauftragte des Deutschen Bundestags
Eva Högl befürchtete schon 2011 dass ich
mit dem Aussetzen der Wehrpflicht
innerhalb der Bundeswehr
Parallelgesellschaften entwickeln können
neun Jahre später schien sich ihre Sorge
zu bestätigen
angesichtsrechtsextremer Vorfälle in der
Elitetruppe der Bundeswehr KSK Kommando
Spezialkräfte spricht sich die
werbeauftragte der Bundesregierung Eva
Högl nun wieder für den Pflichtdienst
aus so würde ein größerer Teil der
Gesellschaft dienen
rechtsextremistisches Gedankengut können
sich dadurch in der Truppe nicht so
schnell verbreiten richtig ist aber auch
dass es in der Bundeswehr immer wieder
solche Vorfälle gegeben hat sowohl vor
als auch nach dem Aussetzen der
ich kenne keine Studie die sagt dass wir
seit Aussetzung der Wehrpflicht mehr
Rechtsextremismus in der Bundeswehr
haben und nichtsdestotrotz ist es
natürlich ein Unterschied ob ich aus der
Breite der Gesellschaft einziehe oder
vielleicht nur bei Menschen die in einer
gewissen Art und Weise vororientiert
sind auf das militärische kommen wir zu
den Argumenten die gegen eine Rückkehr
zur Wehrpflicht sprechen Nummer eins die
Generationengerechtigkeit von der
Wehrpflicht wären in Deutschland die
jungen Menschen betroffen sie werden
aber in den kommenden Jahren eh schon
mit genug Probleme beschäftigt die ihnen
vorangegangene Generationen vermacht
haben also ich glaube am aller
präsentesten ist natürlich irgendwie der
Klimawandel und wie wir da gerade so
noch die Kurve bekommen aber natürlich
geht's auch irgendwie um Themen wie
soziale Gerechtigkeit aber auch was
passiert irgendwie mit unserem
Rentensystem in der Zukunft Kritiker
finden ist ungerecht wenn diese
Generation nun auch noch zu einem Dienst
für den Staat verpflichtet wurde sie
tragen bereits genug Verantwortung auf
ihren Schultern so das Argument darüber
hinaus waren es insbesondere junge
Menschen die in den vergangenen Jahren
aufgrund der Pandemie in ihrer
Entwicklung beschnitten wurden und da
habe ich schon Sorge so ein bisschen
dass wir auch eine verlorene Generation
am Ende bekommen weil einem die ganzen
Erfahrungen dann am Ende fehlen die Idee
sie jetzt zu verpflichten wurde in der
Vergangenheit unter anderem von der FDP
stark als Eingriff in die
Selbstbestimmung kritisiert die junge
Generation ein Jahr von qualifizierter
Ausbildung und Arbeit abzuhalten das ist
nach der Pandemie und angesichts auch
unseres Fachkräftemangels ökonomisch und
gesellschaftspolitisch falsch ein
weiteres Argument des gegen eine
Rückkehr zur Wehrpflicht spricht ist
ihre umsetzbarheit das aktuelle
Wehrpflichtgesetz hat den
Grundwehrdienst zum ersten Juli 2011
nicht abgeschafft sondern ausgesetzt er
würde dann wieder aufleben wenn der
grundgesetzlich geregelte spannungs-
oder Verteidigungsfall festgestellt
wurde
damit das passiert müsste der Bundestag
mit zwei drittelmehrheit feststellen
dass es deutsche Staatsgebiet mit
Waffengewalt angegriffen wird oder ein
bewaffneter Angriff kurz bevorsteht dass
dieser Fall in naher Zukunft Eintritt
halten ExpertInnen für unwahrscheinlich
ungeachtet des russischen angriffskriegs
die Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht
lässt sich meines Erachtens nur dann
sicherheitspolitisch begründen wenn wir
eine direkte territoriale Bedrohung
haben die haben wir nicht das muss man
ganz einfach sagen zudem bezieht sich
die ausgesetzte Wehrpflicht nur auf
Männer wenn auch Frauen mit einbezogen
werden sollten müsste das Grundgesetz
dafür geändert werden auch dafür
bräuchte es eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit
und das sowohl im Bundestag als auch im
Bundesrat experten gehen außerdem davon
aus dass es heute vor allem an
Infrastruktur mangelt um den Wehrdienst
wieder einzuführen und es deshalb
mehrere Jahre dauern würde bisher
wirklich umgesetzt werden könnte genauso
der fatal oder naiv wäre die Annahme wir
könnten sie jetzt mal eben so wieder
einführen oder wieder in Kraft setzen
weil wir haben die Kasernen nicht mehr
wir haben die Ausbildungsstrukturen
nicht mehr das heißt wir würden
wahnsinnig viel Geld Zeit und Personal
nur dafür aufwenden um das wieder
aufzubauen dafür die Jahre dauern dass
es Kraft und Geld die uns ein anderer
Stelle wo es gerade wichtiger wäre
fehlen würden tatsächlich gilt es
aktuell als unwahrscheinlich dass die
Wehrpflicht zurückkommt die Ampel hat
das Thema nicht auf dem Plan
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sagte kürzlich
in einem Interview die Rückkehr der
Wehrpflicht gebe derzeit Zitat keinen
Sinn doch welche Alternativen gibt es
dann um die Trendwende Personal bei der
Bundeswehr doch noch umzusetzen eine
Möglichkeit könnte darin bestehen
Menschen ohne deutschen Pass den Zugang
zur Bundeswehr zu ermöglichen dafür
könnten Anreize wie zum Beispiel eine
vereinfachte einen Bürgerin geschaffen
werden diese Idee wird allerdings schon
seit mehreren Jahren in Erwägung gezogen
bisher aber ohne Konsequenzen was halten
Sie von der Idee die Wehrpflicht in
Deutschland wieder einzusetzen schreiben
Sie es mir gerne in die Kommentare und
abonnieren Sie auch gerne unseren Kanal
wenn Sie gerne mehr von Kontext sehen
würden schauen Sie sich doch auch einmal
diese Folge an in der wir uns der
deutschen Rüstungsindustrie widmen und
wenn Sie noch mehr über den aktuellen
Zustand der Bundeswehr wissen wollen
dann empfehle ich Ihnen dieses Video